en choeur elle chante l'hymne ukrainien
à paris plusieurs centaines de personnes
se sont rassemblées pour soutenir
l'ukraine contre l'invasion russe même à
la tombée de la nuit les couleurs
ukrainiennes continue d'être brandie par
les manifestants et parmi eux des
ukrainiens venus exprimer leurs
inquiétudes toute ma famille est là-bas
et j'ai trop peur pour mes années
on a tous choqués on a vraiment besoin
date parce qu'il faut que tout le monde
réagit
des mobilisations organisées un peu
partout dans le monde comme ici en suède
ici au royaume uni ou encore au liban
tous dénoncent une attaque surprise au
pied de la porte de brandebourg à berlin
les manifestants réclament plus de
sanctions contre la russie aux etats
unis c'est la crainte d'une guerre
mondiale qui anime les esprits de ces
new-yorkais
ce n'est pas seulement la guerre
d'ukraine
c'est une guerre contre l'humanité
contre la démocratie
des mobilisations dans le calme à
l'instar de celles organisées à moscou
près de 800 russes ont été arrêtés pour
avoir bravé l'interdiction de manifester